5 55 here on your wednesday morning got
a viewer complaint about headlights or
the lack of using them lyanna writes
please remind your viewers that they
must turn on their headlights
at dusk not only is it the law but it's
dangerous to drive without him at night
she writes that some drivers seem to be
under the mistaken impression that
daytime running lights
that they're okay in these newer cars
but they are not she says most daytime
running lights
do not provide tail lights until the
actual lights are turned on
a car can essentially be invisible from
the rear
until the brakes are applied she writes
i've witnessed several near accidents
and i was almost
in one of them so drivers consider
yourself reminded now here's an idea you
know
how most cars these days make a noise
when you leave the headlights on and you
open the door after you turn the car off
you know that sound well wouldn't it be
cool if the car could make that same
noise when you
start driving at night and you have
forgotten to turn the lights on
hmm thanks for writing indiana you can
find the online version of this
and all our stories at 8newsnow.com when
you click traffic then driving me crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put on
the phone if there is something driving
you crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com